mit ihrem einsatz belegen wir kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
[Musik]
1300 zuschauer im restlos ausverkauften
congress haus james bond zog gestern
nacht das publikum mit den waffen eines
mannes in seinen bann fünf tage zuvor
hatte regisseur michael steiner an
selber stätte das zurich film festival
eröffnet mit einem drama das auf ganz
andere art und weise zu fesseln musste
wir zeigen wie das kino hier im
kongresssaal heimisch wurde und was man
sonst noch über die siebzehnte ausgabe
des zurich film festivals wissen sollte
[Musik]
wir kommen auf den kulturplatz ja seit
knapp einer woche zieht das zurich film
festival wieder alle augen auf sich und
besonders viel aufmerksamkeit bekam
bisher der kontroverse eröffnungsfilm
michael steiners neuestes werk und
morgen seid ihr tot
pinkelpause auf einer pakistan reise ein
kurzer stopp der alles verändert
das drama und morgen seid ihr tot
erzählt die geschichte des schweizer
paares daniela widmer und david o
entführt und verschleppt ein traum im
film authentisch eingefangen
realität für mich als großes kriterium
sie eine zusammenarbeit mit dem michael
steiner immer wieder zurück so dass nach
der wahl
es ist mir einfach ist großer saal ich
dann mit dem filmstar und es ist
gelungen das paar erfüllt sich einen
nicht ganz ungefährlichen traum
begleitet durch polizei oder militär
reisen die beiden der alten seidenstraße
entlang nach indien doch auf der
rückreise werden sie im pakistanischen
loralai entführt und 500 kilometer weit
nach miran shah verschleppt ins
stammesgebiet der taliban
eine qualvolle geiselhaft beginnt
sie harren aus auf einem hof in diesem
leiden an hitze hunger durst und
krankheiten
dazu kommt die tägliche todesangst
inmitten des kampfgebiets zwischen
pakistanischer armee und den taliban
nicht minder gefährlich die tödlichen
drohnen der usa doch etwas anderes ist
noch schlimmer als erwartet
zahllose
fischer schon relativ vor besondere
situation wird einfach wird noch viel
länger also ist es bildet sich eine
ewigkeit geworden der schwarze loch drin
der film schildert diese situation
voller ungewissheit in bedrückenden
bildern auch zwischen dem paar gibt es
spannungen
doch der ungebrochene wille zu überleben
schweißt zusammen
stockholm syndrom war sehr bewusst ist
es hat ja wie sie im führerhaus einer
größter es geht immer was den führer
fans sicher verbinden mit geißler dass
er natürlich auf beiden seiten
stattgefunden das sicher strategie
twitter-nutzer rebellieren respekt vor
ihnen das lager und löste
es
ist eine berühmte persönliche geschichte
die regisseur michael steiner erzählt
aber auch eine vielschichtige in der die
taliban mehr sein sollen als
klischeehafte bösewichte mir sehr
wichtig
das antwortete erste station sich falk
outdoor sind aber immer dass dir das
dass ich ungefähr eine ahnung was
verliebte
das geht so differenziertes bild von der
empfehlung ist nicht auf schwarze masse
wovon taliban ohne kran war
unterscheidet anders sind ganz klar
definierte persönlichkeit
während ihrer gefangenschaft gewinnen
die geiseln einen einzigartigen einblick
in das konfliktbeladene leben in diesem
kriegsgebiet von dem man im westen kaum
etwas weiß
auch daran lässt der film teilhaben
gleichzeitig die taliban aber eigentlich
immer der kraft sie war sehr stark
vorantreiben bevölkerung dort und und
mein geschirr im sommer die taliban im
winter ist mir die menschen aber
natürlich ist es so zur kurve des
cannabiskonsums stellen sie wenig strom
sollte frühestens wasser toilette kein
wasser kanalisation also wann sind das
was der mensch einfach mussten oder
italien haben die ganze bevölkerung die
paar stunden wie die arbeit ausbildung
russische region ohne bildung nicht
einfach google das ist einfach den mund
so fällt die stimme der moschee geht das
vor und das ist sehr anfällig für sich
radikalisieren wir halt morgen team
einig gehört trotz verständnis die
todesgefahr bleibt die geiselnehmer
fordern lösegeld von der schweiz er ist
1,25 millionen dollar später gar 50
millionen die verhandlungen stocken die
geiseln fürchten um ihr leben
während die schweizer behörden um eine
lösung ringen riskieren die geiseln
alles und planen nach 259 tagen in
gefangenschaft die flucht ein moment der
unachtsamkeit der wächter und es gelingt
ihnen sich bei der mond aus dem hof zu
schleichen in einem riskanten nacht mars
können sie sich zu einem pakistanischen
posten durchschlagen und sind gerettet
bei ihrer rückkehr in die schweiz werden
sie aber nicht als helden gefeiert
im gegenteil ihre flucht auf eigene
faust wird angezweifelt sie seien dank
einer geheimen lösegeldzahlung durch die
schweiz frei gekommen zudem hätten sie
fahrlässig gehandelt selber schuld ist
der tenor
die schlagzeilen sind voller häme
[Musik]
es ist schwierig sie das heißt mit dem
medialen einige fertig ist überdies mit
der kritik mit der schuldfrage mit der
flucht und wo es nicht glaubt
die kommentare im internet
regisseur michael steiner lässt keinen
zweifel daran auf wessen seite er steht
mir geht es darum dass man beim
anschlagziele lässt dass man die
verdrehen gelockt und ist bereit das
schicksal vermeiden bedeutet und beim
einiger vorschlag gemacht weil das man
dir nicht sofort aber hinterfragt und in
verschiedenen ich da meine vielleicht
noch mal recherchiert und morgen seid
ihr tod berührt und wird auch zehn jahre
nach den damaligen ereignissen noch aus
zudem gelingt es dem differenzierten
drama einem die taliban näher zu bringen
so nahe wie man ihnen als fremdling aus
dem fernen westen konnte
[Musik]
ja und jetzt teilweise letztem jahr im
zdf der donau geht christian jungen
findet sie sich im kongress sowie time
is ja man das heimspiel kommt auch mit
der öffnung warum michael steiner sinn
und morgen seite tod zeigt hand und das
ist ein großer kenner und fdp damit nur
premiere 4 wie zum beispiel hatte james
bond hat baut er verstarb finde es geht
auch workshops das zff organisiert wir
haben ja immer kinder workshop in mir
waren klingt aus kinorolle führer und
pastell wohl influenza schauspielerin
ist hat mit den kids träne clips und das
ist symbolisch mehr belegt ein großer
schwerpunkt bietet nachwuchsarbeit und
das kids are showing größte kino der
vertiefung der schweiz zeigte bei der
priorität tempels und es sind außerdem
verhandlung da hat an den us kongress
auf einen zahlen die rolle gespielt
nämlich bei der premiere von james bond
wo er fast gleichzeitig zu landen inzell
stattfinden wir haben das geschafft der
trumpf oder ein finger gestochen hat ist
dass apple das kongresshaus don't like
location ist muss blake sie und wie
vernehmung sagte der kurs ja aber doch
hinter den ohren uns überall brems
mocking auf da auch hier einen film und
das hat sie dann nur überzeugt jetzt
sind sie schwerer folter und journalist
bond james bond hat der vielleicht ein
anders gesetzt hat sich gerne als
fotojournalist
gestand zudem moderner mary und jetzt
effizient ich sage ich schwärme für
james bond ja ich bin ja ein exil wo
über den mainstreams nazmi kämpft hatte
james bond schwimmer krug und ich
allerdings im kino verbot über codes
wintertouristen james bond frischer und
im land mit dem pierce brosnan als james
bond ist sie machtlos von sigi stock
saic motor wieder zieht schönheitsideal
futter zieht und insofern ist daniel
craig ein richtiger bones für die
nullerjahre
belehren der james bond athletischer
muss größer interpretiert hat und das
passt zu unserer zeit wohl im kino chris
stellen damit tattoos gut ausgesehen
danke für das gespräch ließ den jungen
james bond begeistert seit 60 jahren
keine frage auch wenn sich die figur des
agenten der vermeintlich alles kann
enorm gewandelt hat pünktlich zum
internationalen kinostart von no time to
da haben wir die entwicklung des ewigen
playboy hin zum modernen unter die lupe
genommen
ein bisschen verstaubt kommen diese
sechs weißen herren schon daher doch
dank unermüdlicher debatten über
männerbilder und gender rollen hat sich
die figur ein wenig gewandelt klar bond
trägt immer noch anzüge fuchtelt mit
waffen herum und sprengt dinge in die
luft aber im lot heim 23 kämpft er seite
an seite und vor allem auf augenhöhe mit
feindlichen agenten und auch wenn das in
diesem trailer bilder nicht so
rüberkommt 007 spricht in diesem film
über gefühle und zeigt auch seine softe
seite vor rund 60 jahren hätte ein
solcher bund definitiv nicht
funktioniert
[Musik]
1962 sean connery beim ersten einsatz
als geheimagentin dr james bond
unabhängig selbstbewusst elegant ein
chauvinist der sich alles erlauben kann
das machte bond aus sagt filmkritiker
wolfram knorr zunächst einmal ist er
natürlich ein macho durch und durch das
ist mal wichtig er hat nur deutlich
gemacht der wirkliche macher der der
hier zeit wo es lang geht das bin ich
und das ist der mann das war von anfang
an entscheidend und dass man muss auch
berücksichtigen das war natürlich auch
die zeit damals der britische autor ian
fleming erfand die figur 1953 kurz nach
ende des zweiten weltkriegs war die
gesellschaft im umbruch die ehe als
einziger lebensentwurf empfand so
mancher als einengend
007 verkörperte ein luxuriöses
junggesellenleben von dem die meisten
männer nur träumen konnten
wohl kein zufall dass die erste ausgabe
des männermagazins playboy im gleichen
jahr erschien wie der erste bond roman
sagt filmkritikerin simon maier
ist nur spielt die schöne sache
schöne frauen eine unfassbare garten
gerade die schönen frauen waren wichtig
verbund auch wenn er sich nicht binden
wollte sollte klargestellt werden schwul
ist er ganz sicher nicht
bis
1971 verkörperte sean connery den
geheimagenten für viele ist er der
einzig wahre bund die die nach ihm kamen
hatten es schwer zu lesen roger moore
und timothy dalton schliefen und
schossen sich nicht ganz so erfolgreich
durch die jahrzehnte
echte veränderungen bekam erst pierce
brosnans bond zu spüren
1995 übernahm eine frau die produktion
der bond-filme auch 007 bekam eine
chefin sie ließ ihn wissen was sie von
ihm hält
2006 schlüpfte schließlich daniel craig
in die rolle des agenten und brach mit
der tradition des gefühlskalten machos
dieser bond ist offener
der vermeintlich unverwundbare bekam
eine hintergrundgeschichte und durfte ab
und zu gefühle zeigen sogar tränen
dass der genosse die inszenierung der
hattrick
daniel craig hat seine figur ein
bisschen komplexer gemacht james bond
ist noch immer ein knallharter action
held aber einer der nicht mehr so
verkrampft an veralteten männer bildern
hängt
no time to 3 ist cracks fünfter und
letzter bond film
wer kommt nach ihm
lauter produzentin keine frau wie einige
vehement fordern wenn sie sich nicht
entscheiden können für eine frau um beim
mann bleiben dann müsste es meiner
ansicht nach selbstverständlich ein
schwarzer werden weil das ist jetzt
natürlich die entwicklung so viel ist
klar bond muss farbe bekennen wie es
nach northeim zwei weitergeht wird sich
aber wohl erst im nächsten jahr zeigen
wenn sich der schleier um die zukunft
von 007 lüftet wir haben den ort
gewechselt und sind vom kongresshaus
rüber in die ebenfalls frisch renovierte
tonhalle ja und hier entstand vor
wenigen wochen so etwas wie die
akustische visitenkarte des zdf star
dirigent paavo järvi leitete sein
orchester für die aufnahme eine
komposition die für das zfs zur
erkennungsmelodie werden soll wir haben
diese aufwendige produktion hautnah
mitverfolgt
eine eigene melodie hatte zürich noch
nie
doch nun ertönt sie in voller pracht
die neue komposition mit der das zurich
film festival sein profil schärfen will
um der welt irgendwann eine ähnlich
unverwechselbare identität zu
präsentieren wie kann
dessen intro ist international fast so
beliebt wie das festival selbst
festivalleiter christian jungen setzte
darum alle hebel in bewegung damit auch
zürich ein musikalisches
erkennungszeichen ein sogenanntes signet
bekommt
komponiert wurde das brandneue audio
branding des zff von den geschwistern
beiden weg diego nora und laien auch
bekannt als great gabi sie komponierten
unter anderem die filmmusik für den
schweizer kinohit zwingli oder die
netflix serie die an listet ihr
vierminütiges stück fürs zff soll mehr
als nur schöne musik bieten
kompositionen ganz viel funktionalität
also management die rund um zürich film
festival ist eine komposition die 20
musiker element sommerbauer wo sie je
nach bedarf eine wiese und das vor damit
hintergrundmusik verleger larry
interviews führen und es geht wenn sie
in trees verleiht gießen climax musik
und das ist alles in eine komposition in
verpackt und daraus haben wir ein neues
musikalisches toolkit
filmfestival ueber wo alles die liste
erhält
während paavo järvi das orchester
dirigiert sitzen die geschwister in der
regie das erste mal hören sie ihre
komposition gespielt vom 100-köpfigen
tonhalle orchester zürich
als inspiration für die suite diente
ihnen das einprägsame logo des festivals
komposition heißt the world also es ist
es auch wo liegt wo beobachtet wo bunde
ist und der alte gefühl haben versucht
musikalischer genial mit tritt nicht
mehr hand der anfangs akkord von der
revolutionsetüde vom shoppen
zu zeigen und hat aber nur die harmonie
genau und haben auch eines ganz
besonders stück durchgemacht das heißt
es hätte spitzel die revolution drin
[Musik]
seit zwei jahren ist paavo järvi
chefdirigent des tonhalle orchesters
zürich
als solcher bringt er die großen namen
der klassik auf die bühne
auftragsarbeiten sind normalerweise
nicht sein metier
normalerweise spielen wir musik von
beethoven
schumann schubert stimmen ski
trotzdem halte ich es für eine sehr gute
idee einen jingle für das zurich film
festival aufzunehmen auch nicht
mit dieser netten kleine geste verbinden
wir zwei wichtige kulturelle
institutionen derselben stadt
city und r b musik ist musik und wir
sind keine jobs
für die produktion des musikstücks
wurden keine mühen gescheut die creme de
la creme der zürcher kulturszene spannte
zusammen für das trio beiden weg ein
aufwand der sich allemal gelohnt hat
jedes stimme jede jede gegen jede jeder
rap szene eigentlich schämen wenn die
alimenten anzahl spiele und neue ideen
oberhand und die de vom festival und
alles das dann auch und das spiel die
zuschauer im kinosaal an und das dass
gott genau das klima
[Musik]
bei der aufnahme sorgte the world für
gänsehaut gut möglich also dass die
rechnung des zff aufgeht und kinofans
künftig immer häufiger von diesem
ohrwurm befallen werden
[Musik]
wir sind es da am sachsenplatz der
moderiert mit kollegin kathrin höhne
katrin ist überhaupt nichts los jetzt wo
er als zeitrahmen ist im kongress ja der
große balasz der
filmkongress aber abgesehen von der oben
in etwa alle lied wird eine quasi der
arbeit verbracht haben ich stehe es
gewinne wie immer also klingt richtig
unser heimisches gefühl
kino.to minute sich daraufhin schaffen
die lied aus der industrie aber alle
turnierspiele die anfängt zirkus oder er
im influenza dumme als gottes zdf
reporters sind die persönliche
highlights sofort dass ich auch eine
sehr viel über 6 und sehr viel über
feminismus reden
kann sich eine über die übliche
in dem sie koordinatorin das kids auf
jedem sitz mehr wird mit stereotypen
brechen und wieder wie üblich blick auf
die sächsinnen bringe ich mega spannend
die zkb schätzt dass sowohl nur apps ein
- zu der begegnung mit der großen v6
ikone sharon stone jessica wieso gute
halbe stunde ihrem hotelzimmer stelle zu
bringen
wahrscheinlich wichtig leute und kamera
natürlich weitere interviews upside und
sich dafür für ihre pressekonferenz im
großen stil im großraum entschieden ich
traue dem klima villa sie hat mich
natürlich sagt genau wo die
pressekonferenz die hat sky und zwar hat
die alte kollegin monika schäfer
moderiert trotz oder ziemlich delikate
vorgeschichte wo sie mit der sharon
stone hat
stilvoll und selbstbewusst sharon stone
erscheint und der pressekonferenz sind
ziemlich gewandelt
wir lachten auf dem weg hierher weil die
meisten im ticker zur pressekonferenz
aber ich habe mich entschieden ich komme
in obhut
auf dem grünen teppich ist dann nur gold
gut genug schließlich wird sharon stone
mit dem golden icon award für ihr
lebenswerk ausgezeichnet
für über 140 werke und 40 jahren die
hollywood diva ist sichtlich gerührt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
vielen dank
ich habe mich in meinem ganzen leben von
keinem anderen preis so geehrt gefühlt
wie von diesem
diese ehrung für mein lebenswerk
verdanke ich euch
begonnen hatte ihre karriere 1980 mit
einem auftritt in woody allens stardust
memories als erotische männerfantasie
diese kleine rolle nimmt alles vorweg
was sharon stone später sein wird das
sexsymbol eines jahrzehnts im science
fiction kracher total recall gibt's 1990
die verführerin von arnold
schwarzenegger
zur gleichen zeit zieht sie sich für den
playboy aus und das obwohl der vater sie
lehrte sich den männern nicht
unterzuordnen
mein vater war ein überzeugter feminist
er rief mich früher vom spielplatz weg
und sagte du gibst ja nicht alles weil
du den jungs gefallen willst geh zurück
und zeigt ihnen
dann gab ich mein bestes und aber
gewonnen und die jungs machten nicht
nicht mehr
und genau das ist ein großes problem in
meinem leben
sharon stone kämpfte im
männerdominierten filmbusiness lange und
die richtige balance zwischen
schlagfertiger selbstbestimmter frau und
sexy pin up da kam der erotikthriller
basic instinct gerade recht sharon stone
war hier furchteinflößender wm und
unwiderstehliche femme fatale in einem
er verbuchte beim überschlag machte sie
endgültig zum sexsymbol
fluch und segen zugleich
genau an dieser sensiblen stelle setzte
srf ikone monika schärer vor 25 jahren
an sie traf sharon stone zum interview
um mit ihr über die situation von frauen
in hollywood zu reden kommen wir zu
ihrer karriere mir scheint sie haben
eine strikte karriereplanung sie
posierten für den playboy um in
hollywood aufzufallen dann wenn ich das
so sagen darf spreizen sie die beine in
basic instinct um hollywood zu
schockieren um sich einen namen zu
machen
und ich glaub ich jetzt
in hollywood das
ist
nicht sexy unglaublich es folgte der
ritterschlag als charakterdarstellerin
in casino für ihre rolle als
drogensüchtige gangsterbraut seite von
robert de niro gewann sie den golden
globe und wurde für den oscar nominiert
das hatte einen großen einfluss auf mein
leben mein großer traum als
schauspielerin war es mit de niro zu
spielen mein ziel war es mich neben
robert de niro zu behaupten mit ihm auf
augenhöhe zu sein in einer szene hat er
improvisiert und hat gesagt du bist eine
echt gute schauspieler
[Musik]
ich rauchte eine zigarette schaute ihn
an und dachte ja das bin ich wirklich
weil ich dachte ich habe es geschafft
ich sitze robert de niro gegenüber und
zwar auf augenhöhe
die schauspielerin begegnet auf das
journalisten auf augenhöhe das letzte
mal ist sie mit dem kauf und das mal bin
ich und habe ich noch mal bedankt und
verletzte sich herum trägt hat mich
haupt- größte und
schönste
glänzend schön
und vor allem von kühlt intelligent
[Musik]
ja das war unser ausflug zum zurich film
festival bekommen das wochenende gehört
die stadt hier noch ganz in die hände
der kinofans bei uns geht es nächste
woche weiter mit dem kunsthaus zürich
und zwar mit der eröffnung des
erweiterungsbaus ja und gleich jetzt
geht's hier weiter auf sf1 mit der
sternstunde philosophie meine kollegin
barbara bleisch unterhält sich mit dem
wiener denker konrad paul liessmann über
das lustvolle lebt und davon wünsche ich
ihnen auch ganz viel eine gute woche
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos